a newly open tent city along the Texas
border is at the heart of the National
immigration debate the Trump
administration announced the creation of
the temporary housing facility for
unaccompanied immigrant miners at the
Tornillo port of entry last week now
each tent holds about twenty children
Matea viene al is near that facility in
Tornillo Texas that by the way is about
30 miles southeast of El Paso
Mireya good morning good morning we're
standing about a half a mile away from
that tent city and despite several
requests to get inside we are being told
by the Department of Homeland Security
that this is as close as we can get
right now inside we're being told that
there are roughly two hundred boys
between the ages of 16 and 17 years old
but at its peak at its capacity this
place could house up to four thousand
children now the Department of Health
and Human Services started using these
tents to house unaccompanied minors on
Friday the tents are surrounded by
layers of fencing dirt roads and produce
fields this place is desolate out here
and during the day the temperatures get
extremely hot now some of the miners
staying here were separated from their
families that crossed into the US
illegally Republican congressman will
Hurd was allowed inside the encampment
he provided us with some details and
shared with us what he saw there are ten
facilities facilities that you would see
if you went to any kind of natural
disaster site you know this the tents
kind of like the UN uses there are
twenty kids per tent there's two adults
in the room there's a large cafeteria
facility there is a medical center that
has six medical professionals there
there's two ambulances over the last few
days we've seen these kids playing
soccer outside this morning we heard a
dog so they are trying to give them some
sense of normalcy while they are staying
here there are 11,000 children stayin at
about a hundred shelters across 17
countries some of these minors came here
alone but those that came with their
families are being separated and they
are at the heart of this controversy
Gail Madea thank you